[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys
alsbald ist der valentinstag und
vielleicht habt ihr euch ja schon
überlegt was wir backen wollt oder hat
vielleicht auch noch gar keine idee ich
habe hier was für euch nämlich eine
überraschungs herz eines preis torte das
ganze ist nämlich ein schokoladen herz
und dass es innen hohl das heißt ihr
könnt darin verstecken was ihr möchtet
entweder etwas leckeres gebackenes oder
was gekauft ist oder einen ring falls
eben und dem einen antrag machen wollt
oder falls jemandem einfach eine süße
überraschung eine botschaft
hineinschreiben möchtet dann könnt ihr
das hier tun dann verschenkt ihr dieses
herz kaktus und klein ist holzherr
möchten dazu und dann kommt die
überraschung raus ich finde es richtig
süß ich zeige euch gleich wie man das
herz herstellt aber zuerst möchte ich
mal was backen nämlich einen ski skate
kleine chips habe ich mir gedacht komm
jetzt hier drunter und die sind jetzt
auch schon schön versteckt ich werde
jetzt erstmal mit dem boden der geeks
anfang mit der mürbeteig falls ihr nicht
so viel zeit habt und sagt bohr das
ganze ist ein bisschen zu viel aufwand
dann könnt ihr auch einen käsekuchen
kaufen oder brownies zum beispiel und
die mit schokolade überziehen und schön
verzehren kleine pralinen mit reinpacken
also da könnte auch gerne auf meinem
kanal noch fündig werden da gibt es ganz
viele rezepte oder ihr kauft wie gesagt
was uns versteckt dann drunter wie ihr
möchtet je nachdem wie groß der aufwand
sein soll für die person die er eben
beschenkt oder wie viel zeit er eben
auch habt und ich fange jetzt an mit dem
weg und sage euch mal die zutaten für
den mürbeteig nämlich 80 com zucker
160 gramm kalte butter 240 gramm mehl da
könnt ihr weizen oder dinkel verwenden
etwas salz und vanille extrakt und 1 1
dann kann ich jetzt hier die kalte
butter mit dem zucker das war natürlich
anders hier zucker und hier kalte butter
in der regel geben und das ganze ganz
kurz vor rühren
[Musik]
und dann gebt ihr einfach die restlichen
zutaten dazu
[Musik]
und dann den mürbeteig kurz verkneten
so sind die zutaten gut verbunden ich
habe jetzt hier auch schon mal eine
backform ich werde das ganze täglich zu
bereiten falls sie keine eckige backform
habt dann nimmt gerne runde einen runden
tortenring zum beispiel oder eine
springform denn später wird der
käsekuchen sowieso auseinander
geschnitten von daher ist es komplett
egal wobei bei eckigen förmchen
natürlich der vorteil ist dass ich
keinen verschnitt hab da kann ich das
alles erlösung jetzt gebe ich den teig
da einfach rein der muss jetzt auch
nicht kühl gestellt werden den kann man
direkt weiterverarbeiten und
die rüssel die mache ich jetzt gar nicht
sauber die benutze ich einfach gleich
weiter zum bilde dir sparen und jetzt
einfach schön flach drücken
und wenn es an den händen klebt einfach
ein bisschen mehr benutzen
[Musik]
hier achtet ihr einfach drauf dass der
rand schön abgedichtet ist also das
wirklich der map teig schön an den bug
rand an gedrückt wird damit da gleich
eben keine käsekuchen masse ausläuft
jetzt können wir eine gabel nehmen und
den teig ein stechen damit auch später
schön flach backt und ich hoch backt
oder nehmt einfach eine tankkarte muss
sagen damit jetzt einfach viel schneller
weil ich viel viel mehr zacken habe als
auf einer gabel also hier einfach schön
ein stechen
dann stelle ich den kurz zur seite und
kann die käsekuchen zutaten richten und
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr jetzt
noch eine frucht füllung mit reinbringen
und dafür nimmt er dann einfach 200
gramm tief gefrorene früchte eurer wahl
ich habe jetzt hier einfach einen bären
mixed gebt ihr in einen kleinen topf
unterdrücken mit dem wacker und das
ganze darf dann aufkochen und so ein
bisschen ein kochen bis dann praktisch
eine schöne zähflüssige masse entsteht
und wenn ihr dann dieses fruchtpüree
habt dann dürft ihr es gerne noch durch
ein sieb streichen oder elastisch kerne
und die kleinen bärchen einfach noch mit
drin das ganze darf sagen so ein
bisschen abkühlen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich dann schon mal die
knochenmasse machen
dafür nehme ich 125 gramm weiche butter
170 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
vier eier etwas zitronensaft 500 gramm
quark 200 gramm schmand oder sahne
joghurt 200 konzerne und 45 kommt stärke
der cheesecake masse ist wirklich kein
hexenwerk gibt jetzt einfach die butter
und den zucker vanille extrakt in der
rührschüssel dann wird das ganze schön
verrührt
[Musik]
und wenn die butter zucker masse cremig
verrührt ist kommen die eier
nacheinander dazu dann etwas
zitronensaft magerquark schmand und
sahne dazu rühren und zum schluss noch
die stärke einrühren und
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt hier die käsekuchen
masse rhein erst mal nur bis zur hälfte
wer möchte verteilt jetzt hier noch das
fruchtmus auf der masse
[Musik]
unternehmt ihr euch zum beispiel sonst
stäbchen und könnte es noch so ein
bisschen marmorieren
und verteilt sie es einfach bisschen
gleichmäßiger
[Musik]
es sieht einfach schön aus zink ich sage
jetzt ganz vorsichtig mit der masse so
ein bisschen abdecken ich meine wenn ihr
jetzt nur den cheesecake backt und
diesen effekt haben wollt dann müsst ihr
das natürlich als letzte schicht oben
drauf machen aber diese chips kekse ich
mache die werden ja sowieso noch mit
kuvertüre überzogen deswegen muss ich
jetzt leider abdecken schöne geschichte
schön glatt streichen und dann kommt der
cheesecake in den vorgeheizten backofen
und darf da gebacken werden für etwa 50
minuten das variiert natürlich so ein
bisschen je nach backofen je nach
backblech oder backform plus/minus zehn
minuten und dann werde ich den ofen
ausschalten und ihm im ofen noch mal für
etwa 30 minuten abkühlen lassen und
danach ist ganz wichtig rausholen am
besten bei der kälte rausstellen
abgedeckt natürlich und dann muss das
ganze schnell ins gefrierfach damit ich
später schöne cheesecake bei zu
schneiden kann falls ihr das ganze nicht
so aufwendig machen wollt ihr könnt
natürlich auch im käse kuchen kaufen ich
weiß das denn die kohle zum beispiel
wenn sie die gis kicks sticks nach macht
dann nimmt sie einfach so und werde ich
einen käsekuchen und macht den aber so
kann man halt geschmacklich schon noch
mal muss ich sagen so eine besonderheit
mit reinbringen und das selber machen
aber gar keine zeit hat dann dürfte ich
dir noch etwa kaufte die deko später das
ist das besondere und da geschmack nicht
mit cyber waffen
[Musik]
hot cheese cake ist jetzt gerade im
gefrierfach und kühlt ab währenddessen
können wir schon mal die herzform machen
und dafür braucht ihr einfach eine herz
silikonform das ist so ein schönes
geometrisches herr wird 3d und diamant
herz damit kann man zum beispiel auch
kuchen machen und eine muss rein füllen
oder eine creme und einfrieren der
working poor täter riss zu bereiten man
kann tatsächlich auch drin backen wobei
ich sagen muss ich pack nicht so gerne
in silikon förmchen aber man kann drin
backen sie können doch ein ganz normaler
marmorkuchen zum beispiel machen und den
über ziehen aber wie gesagt wir benutzen
das jetzt um den schokoladen hohlkörper
zu machen gehört ich habe ein kleines
mini und ich nehme jetzt dafür ruby
schokolade ruby ist also die vierte
schokoladensorte neben vollmilch
zartbitter und weißer schokolade camel
schon genommen und bereits temperiert
ihr seht auch in vielen anderen videos
wie das funktioniert und das ist jetzt
auch ganz wichtig wir haben es hier auch
schon schokoladen probe gemacht die es
auch schon fest geworden und jetzt werde
ich hier das ganze einfüllen und gibt
jetzt erstmal so eine große menge rein
und streicht so schön am rand hoch
[Musik]
und damit der boden jetzt nicht so dick
wird einfach schön abschütten um mit der
palette eine schöne gerade kannte ziehen
sobald es geht
ja
ein konditormeister
ich achte darauf dass weder der boden zu
dick ist noch dass der rand hier zu dünn
ist und die künste auch in zwei
schichten machen weil sie ihr könnt ihr
könnt es einfach auch schon mal hier in
den kühlschrank stellen 23 minuten
warten solange bleibt die schokolade
auch flüssig wenn nicht er wer mich sie
noch mal kurz und dann kommt noch eine
schicht darüber und ich will die
restliche quartiere für ella hier rein
da kannst du nämlich noch ein paar
chocolatiers machen okay gut und das
lassen wir dann schon richtig gut aus
herten es dauert nicht zu lange aber so
eine stunde sollte die schokolade schon
mindestens auswerten
[Musik]
der käsekuchen ist jetzt gefrorener hat
jetzt auch schon ihre lollis
herausgelöst und
dekoriert jetzt und ich löste im käse
buchen jetzt aus der backform und
schneide ihnen dann in feine stücke ich
hatte dir jetzt schon im gefrierfach
erwartet die schokoladen
das meine ich geb dir gleich
ich geb dir sofort
ja
der inspektor spürnase
mussten sogar als airline täglich
arbeite ich halte die andere strom
die beschicker bosna passau
ist die folie direkt runter weg
dann kenne ich den rahmen lösen
und jetzt ist es am besten wenn ihr
kleine quadrate zuschneidet ich nehme
jetzt hier meinen torten einteiler den
mit den 30 stück und dann habe ich
schöne quadrate
leicht andrücken
dann am besten noch mal versetzt drauf
damit ihr kleinere quadrate hat und auch
noch markieren
[Musik]
die äußere schicht schneide ich jetzt
weg den kuchen kann man ja so schön
essen
ist lecker aber ich möchte jetzt einfach
diese perfekten schnitte hier innen
haben und deswegen schneide ich dort den
rand mal weg
und dann die quadratische hin zu
schneiden und am besten das messer immer
wieder schön reinigen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann diese käsekuchen
stückchen also dieser käse kuchen backt
könnt ihr sie im quartier tauchen ich
habe jetzt hier weiße kuvertüre
temperiert habe hier noch
gefriergetrocknete himbeer und jetzt am
besten so
am besten mit dem kopf nach unten also
mit der oberfläche nach unten eintauchen
dann mit der gabel einmal zu reden
da fordert so ein bisschen übung aber
normalerweise bekommen was mit einer
schwungvollen bewegungen hin
wer ist denn abklopfen
mir die länge eintreten sind sie
wirklich perfekt fest und haben dann
auch gar keine krümelchen der ausbildung
also da können durch ruhig gern mehr
zeit nehmen
dann auf eine folie absetzen
und brachte
und wer möchte kann die regierung hat
neben bildung draufsetzen
das ist der hammer branche voll die
schokoladen muster
elija
rhein main stream wirklich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im kopf
da oben
was man glauben
wie ist da stehen geworden
wie ist er geworden
irgendwie ist es
ja gut
vielleicht weil im dorf
ist gut
dann bin ich entwickle ich jetzt aber
soweit und alles kann angerichtet werden
die chips sind werde die küche ist
wieder sauber und hier habe ich auch
schon eine platte jetzt löst ihr jedes
herz am rand erst mal ganz vorsichtig ab
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen weiße
kuvertüre übrig und habe die auch in
einen spritzbeutel geführt
jetzt vorsichtig und geduldig sein
jetzt könnt ihr gerne zum beispiel noch
die oberfläche ein bisschen dekorieren
oder auch so lassen ich finde dieses
geometrische herz ist so schon echt
schön aus aber wie gesagt ich habe zwar
noch weiße kuvertüre die kommt jetzt
darauf
[Musik]
ein bisschen himbeeren und zum beispiel
am rand noch drauf und ich mein ja
[Musik]
erlaubt das ist der hammer weil schwarz
so mache ich das jetzt
manch wir sollten eine überraschung
reinpacken
[Musik]
genau kohl coole idee guck mal das pack
ich zur seite
verlieren
die kamera oder fremd verstecken
ich habe mir eine schöne tortenplatte
genommen und da könnt ihr jetzt quasi
alles darunter verstecken was ihr
möchtet entweder macht ihr so dass ihr
euer herz jetzt vorsichtig umdreht
befüllt die platte draufsetzt und
umdreht oder ihr macht es einfach so
dass ich nicht allzu viel rein füllt
denn ich will schon beim zerbrechen das
alles schön drapiert und angerichtet ist
deswegen lege ich mir hier alles hin zum
einen nehme ich jetzt hier diese
cheesecake bei zum anderen habe ich auch
noch hier diese pralinen die wir auch
noch gefüllt haben was ich auch noch
reinmachen wäre sind die hippies hier
haben wir hier mit philipp zusammen
gemacht und zwar in den sorten vanille
wäre und himbeere also deren mischung
und himbeeren und da suche ich mir
zapatero seinen und pinkfarbenen raus
und zwar ist es einmal vanille und
einmal himbeere und dann kommen hier
noch die pearls mit rein ein paar
herzchen und ich weiß es ist gerade
keine erdbeersaison und keine himbeer
saison aber fürs bild glaube ich sie das
echt ganz gut aus deswegen da war die
auch noch mit rein
die schmecken alle ghana ja
normalerweise werden nicht aber ist egal
jetzt zum valentinstag ist mal erlaubt
darf ich dann ja ja bis dahin auch
probieren
die 1238
[Musik]
wäre nach himbeere
schlecker
hast du super gemacht so ein paar mit so
übernehmen
aber bringt die stäbchen wieder mit ok
sie können ja nicht mal wieder benutzen
diesen wieder verwendbar nicht
wegschmeißen ya
konan mehr kaufen aber man muss ja nicht
wegschmeißen wenn man so noch benutzen
kann ich lege den kurz zur seite und
macht hier kurz fertig ok und dann rufen
hat den papa und dann kriegt er die
große überraschung ja und da solltet ihr
darauf achten beim anrichten ihr könnt
ja auch so ein bisschen mit dem silikon
herz quasi schauen ob es alles drunter
passt und alles was unter silikon herz
passt mit bisschen weniger raum wegen
der schokolade passt eben auch unter
schokoherzen
[Musik]
vielleicht nicht die großen deals zu
groß
fortsetzung dies zu großer
teil des herzens
das kunst oder kann das weg und bei ella
ist das kunst oder kann das essen
[Musik]
ela bereit fürs herz die
rosenblätter
richtig romantisch
ok also
dann wäre unsere überraschung bereit was
meinst du denn wir haben jetzt darunter
kuchen versteckt diese kleinen
cheesecake törtchen und bisschen was
süßes und obst und früchte und alles was
kann man denn da noch drin verstecken
[Musik]
das könnt ihr noch einige überraschungen
putin mein kollege zum beispiel was kann
man denn noch am valentinstag
verschenken
womit kann man jemanden voll überraschen
ich mein papa nicht wir sind ja schon
verheiratet aber vielleicht gibt es ja
jemand den antrag machen möchte den
heiratsantrag was kann man dann
verstecken
weiß warum
was ist wenn jemand verliebt ist dann
wollen den heiratsantrag machen
das ist sehr eklig aber papa nicht
darauf geheiratet
egal was mein stellen wenn jemand von
den zuschauern zum beispiel verliebt ist
und dann können wir doch hierzu bringt
rum verstecken ja
vielleicht ja das heißt nur bei papa und
mir war es täglich oder wie
[Musik]
ich glaube wohl jetzt den paparazzo zum
probieren oder
machen wir also ihr könnt wie gesagt
alles darunter verstecken ich finde es
eine schöne idee und vor allem in die
schokolade gut temperiert ist dann hält
es ja auch bei raumtemperatur das heißt
ihr könnt es auch schön in den karton
einpacken und einfach schön verschenken
den holzhammer dazu damit man eben das
herzchen schon auf klopfen kann wird wir
räumen kurz auf und dann probieren war
eine überraschung für dich ja was habt
ihr gemacht wurde ist ja immer kraft
du hast schokolade an der stirn
was ist das
wieso bin ich ein elefant
okay das ist die mama und das ist die
ok wer ist hier in dem herz gefangen
eine überraschung mit krieg richtige
überraschung raus
mit dem hammer mit dem mama kaputtmachen
erlauben ist ja dass wir es wirklich
machen
ok jetzt übrigens gesagt das ist echt
eklig wäre wenn wir zwei doch mal
heiraten würden jährlich in deutschland
heiraten besser ich täglich auch du bist
ein
mit küste und so wird das kolleg
und noch mal so
ich mag
[Musik]
das herz ist gebrochen
ala
wow
und erfasst die sterneküche weil es ja
das ist echt sterneküche system i ich
finde es auch sich anständig essen
schneller kriege ich glaube mit mir mein
restaurant reingeht und man bekommt so
was also
wir haben den habe ich doch so ihn so
klein da könnte man das exzellente
findest du mir mein freund gerade
zuschaut und zwar der tristan brandt ist
ein zwei sterne koch hat ein ganz ganz
tolles restaurant in heidelberg ist eine
coole geschichte eigentlich mehr cool
für valencia ich kann dir eine profi
kann die drachen zur seite stellen denn
da muss ich sagen ist ein richtiger
profitiert angriffe drauf schmälert
kommentiert sie selber gemacht ganz
alleine mit ruby schokolade
zumindest ein paar ist nicht gefühlt
aber legen sind dass ich das kann bums
das lassen wir jetzt so schatz die fotos
was haben aber später darf ich noch mal
drüber
[Musik]
war
also in der sternegastronomie hat man
natürlich nur ein törtchen ein
scheinchen
und ein hauch von
klaus schönfelder hat hat super geklappt
folge und ist noch versteckt
also
an alle verloren ich meine man muss das
ganze auch was ich dazu sagen nicht mit
romy schokolade machen man kann die
aussaat bitter war es voll mit karamell
schokolade alles was ihr möchtet
probiert euch gerne mal aus und ich
hoffe dass einem ein anderes taxi denen
bei euch gut ankommt und dass er selber
ausprobieren werdet und falls ihr was
zum valentinstag nach backt oder nach
kocht dann verdient mich auf jeden fall
in euren stories in eurem postings dann
sehe ich das und dann haben wir dieses
jahr wieder eine große wald dienstags
community
viel spaß beim nachbarn das nächste mal
viel spaß und wisst ihr was auch gut ist
die sg queis die kann man ja eingefroren
lassen hat sie machen
das waren echte rosen
sagt mir jetzt nicht durch einbußen
gegenüber ich gedacht da ist ja so
opladen dinge
da hast du nicht veräppelt tatsächlich
kommt mir jetzt die wochen nicht essen
und die sind bestimmt gespritzt weil sie
waren weil sie nicht wie wenn ich wollte
es mich reinlegen hast du mich bei apple
wir hatten ja nicht wissen können dass
der die deko auffrisst
[Musik]
ja
betrieben nein
[Musik]